[Applause]
hi everybody so I'm gonna continue in
let's talk about high dimensional
expanders by the way do you hear me this
time so I'm gonna continue with Erie to
talk about high dimensional expanders
and all the spectral treatment of these
objects and in this hour we're gonna
focus on theorem
that's my easel Oppenheim who's also
sitting here we like to call the
trickling down theorem I'll state the
theorem again in a second even though
we're it stated it in the last hour the
reason why we're we're dedicating a full
hour to this to this theorem is because
it demonstrates a very nice phenomenon
in in simplicial complexes where we can
really exploit the the local structure
of the links and actually get meaningful
global behavior so let me just state the
theorem and then we'll discuss it a bit
the theorem is as follows suppose we
have a d-dimensional initial complex
okay and we should think of T of D to be
at least 2 and it's okay to keep on our
mind just the safeword if equal to okay
so all we care about is like vertices
edges and triangles and suppose
those two things the first thing is that
for every vertex okay XV is very well
connected what I mean by very well
connected it is lambda one-sided
spectral expander
and the second the second assumption
which is a bit more technical is that we
also suppose that the underlying graph
of G of X is connected
we have a d-dimensional simplicial
complex it's links are well-connected
one-sided spectral expanders and the
graph the underlying graph of X when we
consider only the vertices and the edges
is if just connected then the underlying
graph is also very well connected what
do I mean it's not necessarily a lambda
one-sided spectral expander but it's
another constant that depends on lambda
lambda over 1 minus lambda so in essence
what does this theorem mean suppose that
we have our simplicial complex and for
every vertex if i look at its
neighborhood its locally a very well
connected graph so from ok then if the
underlying graph itself is also
connected then it means that if like
local connectedness trickles down to the
property of to be well connected also in
the in the underlying graph itself so
this is this is one version of the
theorem where we can take links of the
vertices and infer something about the
global underlying graph a stronger
version of this theorem can actually
take links of higher levels okay and
then use this theorem iterated again and
again to get to get to get good
expansion in our links ok so what do I
mean by this suppose for example now
that D equals 3 ok now I know that for
every for every edge e ok the underlying
graph of the underlying graph in the
link of e is like a lambda I am is like
a lambda one-sided spectral expander
then if I take like if I take this
theorem and I look at
links of vertices okay then if I take a
vertex V and I look inside XV okay
the links of the vertices inside XV are
actually links of edges in the global
graph 2x okay so when when I know good
expansion happens on the level of edges
I can use this theorem to infer a good
expansion in in the links of the
vertices and then I can use this once
again to get to get good expansion also
in the global level so in fact we can
write a stronger version of this theorem
[Music]
yeah I thought maybe I leave the
definition above because I'm gonna use
it but maybe later on our stronger
version is XP a d-dimensional simplicial
complex such that for all phases of code
I mentioned to access is lambda
one-sided actual expander and to the
underlying graph of every link is
connected
then X is also one-sided the one sided
spectral high-dimensional expanded link
of every face in every level of code I
mention at least two of course the
trivial the trivial links of code I
mentioned zero or one can't be connected
because they're either the empty set or
just a bunch of vertices and how much is
this constant well if you compose the if
you compose this function on itself
again and again it it becomes this
function so so this is a bit this is a
bit worse than this however if we know
how to construct simplicial complexes
were on the faces of code I mentioned to
this lambda can get arbitrarily close to
0 then this will also get arbitrarily
close to 0
so we will see in the proof of this
theorem that it uses again a very very
nice idea that yes so if I look at if I
look at this one yeah so I'm just
talking about spectral expanders at the
graph okay yes I'm looking only at the
one skeleton yes
so here there is a completion complex
but actually all we care about are up to
the triangles because I look at like the
I look at these links have graphs
themselves okay but you you are correct
that actually we don't care about higher
dimensional faces okay in this theorem
we already do care about high
dimensional faces however this theorem
is just to reapply this theorem again
and again to trickle down the expansion
yes so that was that was one comment
that I wanted to say if in this theorem
you bound you bound eigen the
eigenvalues of the adjacency operator of
the ague of the global adjacency
operator by the positive side by lambda
and there's also there's also an
analogue theorem or actually you can
state the theorem also for negative
eigenvalues so if i know that all the
eigenvectors of of the links are also
bounded from below by some i don't know
eita
okay so then we will get that the
negative negative eigenvalues also of
of the global adjacency operator will
also be bounded by the same the same
bound ok that's clear from below and in
fact the negative the negative side of
the theorem is even meaningful when this
ETA is equal to minus one which is like
the trivial bound for for for for the
eigenvectors of the adjacency operators
from below okay because they're
averaging operators lambda when the end
is also always bounded from below by
minus one and and what you get from here
is that the lower you go in a high
dimensional simplicial complex the
further bounded you are from below okay
so we didn't discuss this too much but
to be bounded from below is like to be
far from from being bipartite and the
negative part is supposed to sound
intuitive because if we are in a in a
little complex who has many levels whose
dimension is high then of course you're
very bounded from being bipartite
because every vertex because it's it
must be inside at least one D
dimensional face then it means that the
underlying graph okay every vertex like
participates in a very large clique so
I've clicked themselves are supposed to
be very far from being bipartite if the
negative part is supposed to correspond
to this intuition so thank you for that
question
so I'll just say that this theorem again
has like very nice a very nice proof and
I think it's for the proof alone it's
good to like dedicate a full hour but I
should say that the theorem also has
applications as a tool in analyzing
simplicial complexes themselves because
before this theorem was known to show
that some simplicial complex is actually
a aspect a high dimensional expander you
needed to look at the expansion in all
the links and here if you only want a
bound on if you only want a bound on the
expansion of our links you only need to
consider links of code I mentioned too
and you only need to analyze them and to
show something that's usually much
weaker just that I get the underlying
graph of all the other links is
connected so so is how open I am in
tally Coffman also have a nice control
construction of high dimensional
expanders that uses like elementary
group theoretical ideas and there they
they rely on this theorem to only like
analyze links of core dimension to which
have a very nice and relatively simple
description so let's maybe talk about
the intuition of why this thing is
supposed to be true first of all why do
we need this like technical assumption
that the eigen the underlying graph of X
is connected suppose that I have two
copies of the complete complex each one
is supposed to be a very good spectral
expander even two-sided and indeed if I
look at if I look at the completion
complex which are just both of these
copies okay but they're disjoint from
one another they're disconnected sorry
then of course all the links in each
copy seem very well connected so I have
no chance to sense the sense that this
graph if they disconnected even if the
links are very well connected however if
they weren't completely disconnected
they were just I don't know the a sparse
cattiness underlying graph then this
first cut should should have probably
appeared okay in a link of some vertex
in some side
and somehow if this cut was sparse then
you would probably imagine that even in
the link the cut should have been sparse
so then you can say okay so it couldn't
just be you know a few engines maybe I
have to put here another few address and
then somehow you'd imagine that if I put
here more edges than they would be
visible in more links etc etc however
this is less intuition and what we would
see in a moment is that the proof
actually doesn't go in these lines we
actually use other ideas that relate
more to the spectral definition of
expansion so the combinatorial
definition of expansion of connectedness
it doesn't it's not maybe so clear and
this proof how it how it actually comes
into play okay so that's further ado
let's maybe let's maybe prove the
theorem
last hour recall that we will define the
adjacency operator right so if if we
have a function f of the vertices of the
underlying graph then AF is also a
function on the vertices and FV is just
the expectation over all the user gaze
into V of f of U so if this is me and
this is its neighbors then F is just
averaging out all the neighbors of V and
we saw last time that for functions F
and G on this we can define an inner
product that is the global average on
all the vertices of F V times DV and we
saw if we take AF and take its inner
product with some function V is some
function G then this actually
corresponds to this like symmetric
bilinear form when where you choose like
an edge with a direction and then
multiply F of one side times G of the
other side
good so the main idea yes of course so
I'm yeah so I'm taking your expectation
and the expectation is of course
according to the weight in the simply
circumference so it's not it's not just
necessarily uniformly a uniformly random
chosen edge when in fact I'm sampling it
in the way that we talked about last
time where I have a measure on the
triangles or the top level faces and
then I choose according to this and
remove one vertex uniformly at random
until I get an edge
so one of the main own supposed to seat
somehow which you know which way to
chose for the cities there are two
phases that should affect the statements
no statement behind the scene we never
see there oh so now we're gonna exactly
see how the the fracture of the
simplicial complex where we have like
faces that are one above actually
actually give us more information on
this form in fact one of the main ideas
in this proof is that in a simplicial
complex we can actually calculate this
this symmetric bilinear form formed by
the local adjacency operators in the
link so this method where we where we
take some global invariant or global
form and calculate it using using the
local structure is I think it was first
due to to garland here is it in in a
different setting but the spirit is
quite similar so let me write precisely
what I mean okay so suppose F and G are
valued functions on the vertices okay
then first of all I can calculate its
inner product of F and G by first
choosing you and then calculating the
local inner product of F and G inside
the link of view and the second did the
same thing but with adjacency operator
if I look at AF inner product with G
then I can calculate it by using the
local adjacency operators the local
inner products in the links so here when
I say F of U and G of U I just mean the
restriction of F to all the vertices
participating in a vertices
participating in the link of view and
when I write a sub u okay it's just a
local adjacency operator in the link
review when I think of it only as a
graph okay that it's underlying graph so
it's it's a very good question and in
fact the fact that we are looking at a
simplicial complex will allow us to
calculate these global JSONP operator
describe an inner product as a convex
combination of the local inner products
inside the links so let's see
so for the first item F inner product
with G is again just it's just of
expectation over me of F V times DV and
right in here we're like sampling V out
of x0 and let's remember how we sampled
V out of x0 okay we first sampled
sampled like an edge UV and then out of
it right we take one we take we take one
vertex uniformly at random okay and what
do I mean by with sampled UV again we
remember that there is a simplicial
complex so even to sample this edge UV
we may be needed to sample a triangle or
a for face or whatever and then we
removed vertices uniformly at random but
as you can see I can sample this edge in
the marginal of the of this process for
example many high level faces and then
out of it I take V and this will and
this would be the same marginal that I'm
using here to just sample V so so the
point is when I do this process I can
first condition on the vertex that I'm
sampling in the edge but I'm not using
but I'm throwing away okay so this is
equivalent to first first sample you
okay out of out of x0 then sample and
add UV that condition and the fact that
this edge contains you and then just
take the other vertex but this second
step of sampling an edge UV given that
it contains you okay is precisely like
sampling V according to the link of
you okay so if we if we calculate this
through the condition expect conditional
expectation of the few which is sampled
at the other side of this edge this is
again just like first sampling you and
then I output f v GV precisely when I
sample V out of the link of view this is
why I can write here so view this of you
as an inner product in the link of you
it's clear so what should I do for the
second item the answer is exactly the
same so if I look at a inner product
with G this is as we said before just a
sample and edge according to x1 u UV and
outputting f of u GV and again this
sample right I can look at it as
sampling uvw out of the triangles and
then just removing one just removing one
vertex
okay that's taking maybe the first two
and removing the third okay and again
this is equivalent to first sampling W
then sampling a triangle given that W
participates in
and again sampling this triangle given W
precisely because the way we built the
measure on the Lynx is exactly
equivalent to sampling UV inside the
edge set in the link of W okay what we
get here protection over this W of
section you've been inside the link of W
a few G V what we see is that inside
what we get here is precisely the local
adjacency operator moon operating on F
and then inner product with
so in fact this is like this claim that
I wrote over here is like the main
observation that that Israel had that
was in the spirit of Garland's method
and this is like this is like the main
lemma inside the proof I think so let's
prove the theorem
so what do we need to prove let's take
let gamma be some eigen value of the
underlying the global like the
underlying graph of X ok let's call it
adjacency operator a so let's take F be
an eigen function
corresponding to this Gama okay and what
we saw any restock is that without loss
of generality we can request that F will
be perpendicular to the old ones
function and another thing that they
want to assume if that F is normalized
okay it's known as one so what do we
need to show
we need to show that gamma right is less
or equal to lambda over 1 minus lambda
assuming that the eigenvalues of the
local adjacency operators are all less
or equal to lambda so how can I write
this gamma I can write it just as a F
inner product with that because AF is
lambda F and then I can remove it
outside of the inner product and then I
will get precisely this and where
localization claim this is just equal to
expectation on all V a vfv inner product
with F V and when it's clear from the
context I'm not going to write you the
the linkware of where this inner product
takes place and and and good so so now
we like translated the question of how
large this is to a question on a bunch
of local operators so yes maybe I don't
know it's like a naive way to continue
this proof suppose that we could have
shown that if F was perpendicular to the
global oil once function it it will
imply that all these local these local
functions were also perpendicular to
like the local on all one's function in
the link then what could we say we could
say ok so this is a bf FB FB would be
less or equal to lambda fvfv and when I
would take expectation over this right
it would be will be equal lambda and
then we would get like that gamma is
less or equal to lambda so
if I could wish that our lives were
perpendicular to the local Irwin's
function it would be great then I would
prove the theorem and then I would be
happy
however this this is not only something
that we don't know how to prove it is in
fact untrue and like any counter example
we'll show it right even on I don't know
the complete complex what does it mean
to be perpendicular to the global
constant is just to mean that your
weighted average is zero so if we're on
the complete complex I don't know maybe
half the vertices say one and half say
minus one and then we would be then we
would be perpendicular however if I look
at a link in the complete complex right
it's like all the vertices except one
and in this link right even if I was
globally perpendicular locally I have no
idea I can maybe even be in some
functions like largely positive and then
some largely negative all I know is that
the averaging is supposed to be zero so
this doesn't hold so we have no no other
option than to just consider it in our
calculations so let's decompose every
local function
okay - like what we called F 0 plus F
perp okay where F 0 F V 0 + FV / because
we're doing it locally and F V 0 is just
some constant times the local or ones
vector and F and FP perp is just the
component that's perpendicular to it now
let's deal with both of these but both
of these components separately here so
the expectation of a be fvfv it's just
like so what does a V do to each
component so the part which is does just
proportional to the all one's vector it
leaves it as it is right so so this
first part will be just this alpha v 1 v
alpha V 1 this will correspond to the
part here that the constant times the
old ones vector and the part that
perpendicular well I don't know but soon
we are gonna say that that this part is
in fact very small so because because
these local local local adjacency
operators are lambda one-sided spectral
expanders then I can say that if I look
at this
okay it might be very large negative but
if it's positive it's still less than
lambda times the inner product of F V
perp SB perp okay so I can say and this
is like I think the only inequality that
appears here in the proof that it is
less or equal to I leave the first part
as it is
plus lambda F V perp okay so now I have
like two parts that I need to calculate
what is this F V perp and what is this
this 0 what is this alpha being the
scalar that appears here in inside of
the inner product so FB perp will we
will just write it as just FB minus 0
okay and then we can rewrite this as the
expectation over 1 minus lambda the
first term
with lambda f v FV and if we look at the
right hand side we know that FB FB an
expectation is just supposed to be F
inner product with F this is again the
use of the local claim so again this
will be equal to 1 minus lambda the
expectation of the first part
plus lambda so now we're left to
understand right the the problematic
part the part that prevents us to say
that FB is perpendicular the constant
part
so in this special expectation inner
product the inner product of the
constant one vector is always one okay
so this in fact okay the this inner
product is not very sophisticated in
fact we have just alpha B squared
everywhere okay so we're looking at 1
minus lambda the expectation on lambda
so if we will define a function G of V
to be equal alpha V and what we have
here is in fact 1 minus lambda inner
product itself plus lambda for the last
part of the theorem we just need to
understand who is this mysterious
constant alpha v let's just understand
who what it is what should also be be
because this is all ones vector is all
ones vector is part of an orthonormal
basis or in other words its normalized
if I want to understand who this
constant is I just need to project F to
the space that stand by this vector so
in other words this alpha v is just F of
a inner product with this with this
local or one's vector and you can see
that this is simply taking taking the
average of over all vertices in the link
of V of F of U and now again I look at
this experiment I'm taking I'm taking
all the I'm sampling from the link of V
some vertex and averaging out the F of U
were the elements in the links in the
link of V these are precisely right
when the view participate in the link of
V precisely when you as a J's
2v right precisely when the edge UV is
contained inside of X and in fact not
only is this true the sampling process
is exactly I don't identify denti-cal to
to the process of sampling au adjacent
to V and taking F of U so in other words
this is just okay this alpha V is just a
F at point V so in other word and so so
when we plug this back here right we get
that gamma is less or equal
oh sorry
other words forget that gamma is less or
equal to 1 minus lambda AF inner product
with itself plus lambda F F F is just
gamma gamma times F so we get that gamma
is less or equal to 1 minus lambda gamma
squared plus lambda this is excellent
well is this excellent because now I got
I got an inequality that involves both
gamma and lambda and it's maybe a
polynomial inequality but the degree
here is only 2 so I can actually solve
this I know the root formula etc etc so
I can actually I can actually solve this
and get it either gamma is lesser is the
greater equal than 1 or gamma is less or
equal to lambda over 1 minus lambda so
now right it could be either of these
but now I'm going to use the assumption
that the graph is connected ok to say
that my my gamma must be okay so gamma
must be strictly less than 1
since in connected graphs
okay in connected graphs all eigenvalues
except for the trivial one are strictly
less than one so what we get is our
bound so that the eigen any non-trivial
eigen values must be less or equal to
this so I don't know this was maybe like
in a lot of steps and many of them seem
technical but in fact this proof has two
main steps the first one was this
localization claim where where I say
that I can compute AF inner product with
itself by by a convex combination of the
local inner products okay this is like
this is like a very very nice
observation and it really exploits the
specific specific structure and measure
that we had on the simplicial complex
and the second step is to say okay on
the perpendicular part we know that a
kills it that it would be very very
small so all we need to worry about is
the part that that's the part that are
perpendicular the part that is the all
one function times the constant and it
turns out that this constant has a
combinatorial meaning and this
combinatorial meaning is exactly you
know some some how recursive to the two
again this global to this global
adjacency operator this is actually all
there is to it
good so either any question was your
play this just for be equals to what is
it saying what do you mean for the
equals to for normal graph say that each
link is when it's it's also saying it's
goes to look for that open but then I'm
wondering what is so special about this
MX combination so um in a normal graph
the D actually equals one okay the the
edges are like one dimension or
something like that
Oh in in in a graph the the links of the
vertices they have no edges right
they're like zero dimensional if you if
you take a vertex V and you look at all
its neighbors hidden the link will only
be a bunch of isolated vertices so there
is no I don't know there is no apparent
way of of getting something that looks
like a localization and it could be and
it shouldn't be right because there are
some irregular graphs that are great
expanders in some deregulate graph that
or not but the links are look the same
right they look like the isolated let's
say just looking at isolated vertices of
vertex are expanding what you're saying
is like let's ignore the whole
simplicial complex part and just like
look at all the and let's just look at
all the guys that are adjacent to V and
let's that's like called the link of V
like being all these and the sub sub
graphs in induced by them right
yes so exactly looking at this is just
like saying okay let's take a graph and
let's wherever there is a triangle let's
just put the triangle as another layer
and and and again you can ask yourself
if the Lynx would expand in this way or
what measure you should put in the
triangle so it will expand and then
you're not gonna get anything anything
new from this I mean either it either it
does so I think that if you know that
the neighborhoods are expanding then
then you can just apply this theorem
when you think of x2 of the triangle set
just be all three vertices where all the
edges are connected so so the point is
that you need you need to carefully
define how you're going to choose your
triangle so that if you if you choose so
if you choose the the edge of uniformly
at random you'd get the same
distribution on the you know the measure
and edge is uniform and your D regular
I'm sure just actually I'm not so I'm
not so sure anymore because clearly you
could have like you know you can I have
like edges that don't participate in any
triangle and then you have you'd have to
think about it so maybe it's maybe it's
less general
cludes and isolated verdicts oh yes
that's true
so you think there is such a chair yeah
III think that I think that you could
probably maybe under some assumptions of
regularity just reduce it back to this
theorem but I can tell you like a
definite yes
good oh there was an anecdote I can tell
you so someone came to me he's trying to
build like an e democracy story together
yes so they okay I don't want to get
into the details but the point is people
kind of add themselves to your craft
and they choose who to connect to and he
wants to maintain the fact that the
whole rather than expanding all I need
to do if you never someone asks
themselves their neighborhood needs to
look like an expander and then the whole
thing sounds very nice but of course the
city have no idea how to construct such
a thing let alone destroy to you so
maybe this before I finish I'll say that
regarded method technique where you
first look at some global operator
calculate it locally and then and they
then say something about the constant
part okay it's something that can
actually be reapplied in other settings
in simplicial complexes so how do you
use this to actually give a new
construction of expanding do you stitch
together little expanders how do you do
it consistently so that all the links
are expanded yeah so I don't know how to
adjust construction expanders
combinatoric Li
but so so I can't use this theorem as
easy to just construct an expander
because have you say it's not trivial I
don't know how to do it if somebody
already constructed something that he
claims that they claim to be an expander
then I can maybe use this theorem to
like analyze it much more efficiently
because now instead of like analyzing
every link in this maybe maybe very
complicated simplicial complex it's
enough to look at links of a certain
level right of the level of code I
mentioned too right and there if I can
somehow analyze them and say that they
are they there are very good expanding
graphs then I can use this theorem to
say that the expansion trickles down all
the way to the bottom suppose you take
quotients of buildings where all the
links are ready to plane graphs does
this imply that any quotient is an
expander graph
so is it is it naturally as you go down
several layers in the store you have to
lose on the expansion I mean if the
expansion looks like one body you
there's nothing yeah yeah yeah you're
right
like if the expansion is if the lambda
here is half or above then this becomes
a trivial bound right if lambda is equal
half then this is just equal to 1 and
this is meaningless and people know how
to construct people know how to
construct expansion expanders where this
is this is half or above and the graph
is connected so so you can say something
maybe more sophisticated and bound to
bound this bound eigenvalues of the
secretion of complex there so this is by
no means tight ok yes
you can't find simplicial complexes
where it's better they are very good
specs panels yeah
you're asking oh I I get it so you're
saying let's like look at this proof but
instead of looking at links of vertices
let's look at links of edges and try to
infer something directly to them so the
proof will work almost in the same way
and where will we get stuck when we will
try to calculate this sum alpha v and
and apparently the constant that we will
get here would not be any more F of V
okay but it will be maybe again another
operator right it will be like - this is
not a vertex anymore this will be an
edge this will be like an operator where
I have like on one side on the edges
participating and on the other side I
have all the vertices participating and
it will be an average operator of the
bipartite graph where I connect an edge
to a vertex if they all participate in a
triangle okay so this is so in another
work that meaning it have we actually do
spectral analysis of this adjacency
operator and it's the we call it the
complement work because we from an edge
a we pick a vertex V that complements it
to a higher level set but the problem is
that in this proof I don't get something
that relates to gamma again so naively I
I don't know how to say something like
that but maybe
question you're going to approve the tea
from d21 but know that you know the
construction that you don't the places
where we applied this theory then um
that could be very very small so you're
improving it the t21
but lambda could be these are these are
not just expanded did you say anything
about how the 13 dumping implies the
fact that the highest thing in place
when you know two theorems did you say
anything for the second one flies show
theme that if all the top level links
are expanded in the morning HDX yes it
follows from it so it's followed for
follows from the first in the first
theorem just because I like to explain
this maybe when I redraw the diagram
that we saw before right so suppose
suppose I have a very high dimensional
simply cell culture and and this is like
the D minus 2 level and looking at
and I have here the D minus one level
and when I look at the link of somebody
in the D minus two level it's like
taking the simplicial complex that it's
diagram is everything that's drawn here
above so if I look at the D minus three
level right so the it's link is actually
right like the everything that's drawn
above so if I know that all the links in
the demoness two levels are very
expanding then when I look at somebody
in the D minus three level I know that
all its vertex links which we just these
guys are are very well expanders so I
can infer that this is also a pretty
good expand expanded right so now I know
that this this guy's underlying graph is
is also expanding so then if I look yeah
so then if I look one level lower here I
have more links and I can reapply the
theorem
it's a long comment so you can't cut me
I know this we can construct a
simplicial complexes where you have like
D dimension for D large but the top
simply sings or the coordination to have
any small epsilon second eigenvalue that
you want that's a constant may been
enough to you can make it as small as
you want but it doesn't go down so you
would have dropped the epsilon ish
eigenvalues all the way down there so I
don't know act independent so the thing
these are things that if you have 1 over
D over 2 D to get all the way down right
so the question is what is the right
thing like if it is like 1 over D what
happened I don't know that what I know
is that you can get give me any constant
I can build up a three-dimensional
velocity such that you believe me
absolutely but I give you a complex of 1
over epsilon at the t- quadrature to and
everything down is also
I mean it says a little bit of tightness
it's another self ultimately not only
economies that I found it says that you
cannot cope with you if the top
complexes are like 1% in secondary value
for the one we know here true that won't
happen
you couldn't I mean you if you stated
this theorem with the 0.5 because in our
construction it's close to 1/2 just take
the plane facility and cut it and glue
it is those thing and then you can see
that a chicken can be very like right
but the links are still there because
it's a single one
any more anonymous questions please
let's think
[Applause]